c'est le moment que général chaque
attendait depuis longtemps
je suis tellement content dit-elle je
peux maintenant devenir citoyenne
canadienne
la jeune pakistanaise arrivé au canada
en 2008 pour rejoindre sa famille était
le symbole de toute une communauté
après avoir accepté de montrer son
visage un fonctionnaire avant son test
de citoyenneté zune et raich ac a refusé
d'enlever son voile pour prêter serment
invoquant ses principes religieux elle
est allée devant la cour fédérale qui
lui a donné raison
une décision au portée en appel par
ottawa je pense que la plupart des
canadiens et canadiennes trouverait à
enfants sont qu'une personne cache son
identité au moment même où elles
souhaitent se joindre à la famille
canadienne
dans une salle remplie de femmes
musulmanes les trois juges de la cour
d'appel fédérale ont rejeté les
arguments des procureurs du gouvernement
une décision rendue sur le banc pour
qu'elle puisse obtenir sa citoyenneté
dans les plus brefs délais et pour
qu'elles puissent voter dit il aux
prochaines élections si thomas mulcair
évite de se lancer dans le débat et les
tribunaux ont statué comme vous venez de
le dire est qu'on aime ça au qu'on
n'aime pas ça ça relève des tribunaux et
les tribunes on était très clair là
dessus
gilles duceppe lui maintient la position
du bloc on était le seul parti cap
déposé un projet de loi demandant à ce
qu'on voit à visage découvert des
services publics à visage découvert la
fermentation et sous à visage découvert
les femmes ne doivent pas s'effacer de
l'espace doublait même son cloche du
côté de la campagne conservatrice
nous regrettons la décision du tribunal
nous comprenons que le gouvernement
envisage toutes les options juridiques
indique son porte-parole qui réitère
qu'un gouvernement conservateur réélu va
présenter une mesure législative
assurant que personne ne peut prêter le
serment de citoyenneté avec le visage
couvert
generali chaque n'attendra pas jusque là
elle compte bien prêter serment d'ici
quelques jours
elle est votée pour la première fois le
19 octobre
ici daniel thibault radio canada ottawa
nature joie notre chef de bureau à
calgary et emmanuel on le voit
clairement là les conservateurs n'hésite
pas à ramener le niqab dans la campagne
électorale a lancé lynn les
conservateurs sont ultra à l'aise avec
leur position là-dessus non seulement
parce que ça trouve écho auprès de leur
base militante mais auprès l'important
part de l'électorat dans le genre de
compter qu'ils veulent gagner dans cette
campagne n'est qu'à penser aux comtés du
québec qui sont dans leur mire
d'ailleurs jugement de la cour fédérale
ou pas pendant la campagne et j'aurais
ramené cet enjeu là dans la campagne
daniel faisait référence à une mesure
législative le savez déjà été fait dans
les derniers jours de la session
parlementaire en juin dernier le
gouvernement en a déposé un projet de
loi ses 75 pour forcer le vote à visage
découvert conscient que ça n'irait nulle
part
justement dans on affiche la couleur on
veut en parler on veut en faire un enjeu
électoral
ça c'est pour les conservateurs dans la
santé un certain malaise chez thomas
mulcair dans le reportage de daniel
il faut dire que c'est un enjeu qui
divise le npd rappelez vous cette sortie
d' alexandre boulerice à l'époque où lui
avait même suggéré qu'une commission
bouchard taylor
pour l'ensemble du canada y avait de se
rétracter dire que c'était son opinion
personnelle c'est une chose d'avoir des
positions de principe en faveur du port
du niqab ça respecte la charte des
droits et libertés
mais un campagne électorale s'est
patiemment ce que deux plus populaires
de la grande discrétion de monsieur
mulcair là-dessus mais je vous dirais
aussi la grande ducasse ion de justin
trudeau
lui qui aime beaucoup se présenter comme
le grand champion de la charte
canadienne des droits et libertés
on l'a pas vue sur rue et devant un
micro aujourd'hui pour parler de cet
enjeu là comme quoi en campagne
électorale des fois les principes
peuvent aller à l'encontre de ce qui
politiquement populaire merci emmanuel
juste un mot peut-être pour dire que
vous êtes à calgary parce que les chefs
convergent vers la ville pour le débat
économique de jeudi oui rythme de
campagne minimale jusqu'à demain mais
demain tous les regards vont être
tournés vers le dévoilement finalement
du cadre financier du lpd merci emmanuel
au revoir